Hey guys,
If you're looking for good,
sound biblical teachings in truth
- in love - and through the Spirit,
that's not preaching to itchy ears, just what
people's fleshly natures want to hear, but sound
biblical doctrine - then join DLM Men's Lifestyle.
This is the men's ministry you're looking for.
And this is some of what you
can expect to see and hear.
If you're lost, if you're trying to make sense of
the world, trying to make sense of your purpose.
Why you are here, what is your meaning,
then you need to understand that you
can only find the answers in truth itself.
And God himself who created you in His image.
You are not just some random mistake.
You are created in God's image for a purpose.
And He's waiting for you to
near Him, with all your heart.
Trying to get rich quick often leads to financial
ruin because you're doing that... you're walking
in your own will, your own desires.
Fleshly desires.
You're not walking in God's will.
We need to work hard for the
money that we receive.
You need to earn it.
Many of you still look back on your failures and
you're letting it define who you are. There was
definitely a flood and we don't just read that
from the Bible, but from other civilizations.
Not just two or three, but
almost from all of them.
It says that we have to be watchful.
Are you?
Are you always on guard, looking out?
Because we are in a battle
whether you like it or not.
And you need to be watchful.
You need to be careful.
You need to be on guard, being able
to see when evil is attacking you or your family.
You also need to be able to discern, to watch out
there in the world, to see what darkness is doing.
We will all die someday.
You might even die soon.
And then where will you go when you die?
This life is not all there is.
And I want you to be with me in eternal life.
Man, it would be so special if
I can talk to some of you guys.
We might never meet in this life but
in the life after this one, for sure.
God was saying to me - choose me or choose
your dad - and you need to understand my dad
was everything for me.
He was my role model.
Excuse me.
My pillar.
It wasn't easy.
God was saying choose me.
Am I everything to you or do you choose your dad?
It was the same thing He asked Abraham to
sacrifice his son Isaac,
The test to put Him first.
That is the day I fully surrendered to Christ.
I went to China and that is where God told me
to become a preacher, to share His
gospel to the ends of the world.
You see, David did not fight through
the flesh with his own power.
He fought with God's power that
was in him, through the Spirit.
You see, He did not have self-confidence.
He had God-confidence.
You know, I've been called vain
as well when I was younger.
And here's the truth.
I was.
I was vain until God opened my spiritual eyes
and I saw myself for what I was, at that time.
A wretched arrogant human being.
I felt like the worst person ever
when God showed me my pride.
Put God first in your marriage,
in everything that you do.
It is God's Word that says
that you have to love your wife, not
when you feel like it - it's a command.
It's an act of your will, not just a feeling.
The feeling a lot of people focus on - that kind
of love - is the eros love.
Sexual love.
The attraction love.
There's also agape love, which is the
unconditional love that God has for us.
That's the love that you
also have to have for your wife.
To love her even when you don't feel like it.
When we become reborn Christians,
we receive a new spiritual nature.
The Holy Spirit, right?
So we have that nature.
We also still have that old sinful flesh and
when we act through the Spirit, we will not sin.
This new nature helps us to overcome sin,
but when we don't act through the Spirit,
when we act through the flesh, we will sin.
We will fall.
And so not only do we receive the new spiritual
nature, we also become children of God.
He adopts us after He declared us as righteous.
But that doesn't mean that when we sin He will
just think, okay, that's fine and just leave it.
He disciplines us as a good
father because He loves us.
You can trust God with everything in you.
But you cannot always trust people.
People ... you need need to
be very careful in who you trust.
But you can trust God because He knows
what's going on in your life anyway.
He knows everything.
So you need to be vulnerable to Him especially.
But you don't need to be vulnerable to all people.
Evil is taking over is certain areas
causing suffering that's unnecessary,
because we are supposed to be the light in
the world to help the poor - to help the weak.
But a lot of Christian men are doing nothing.
You are called to be the light of the world
and to go and make disciples
of all people. Do you get it?
This world can do what it wants to you, but
if your confidence is in God, you will always
have peace and joy.
It's like the tree.
You know, the rain can come.
The storms can come.
The sun can beat in the day, but
the roots are in the living water.
Join us by subscribing to our channel, where
you can expect to see weekly videos that you
can watch - that you can share - and that you
can comment on with the rest of the DLM family.
This world, and the things of
this world, it's all passing away.
We're in this world but
we're not part of this world.
So join us by putting Christ first
and always remember, life is short.
So don't waste yours.
Bye.